es dauert kaum zehn sekunden auf
mallorca überwältigt ein spezialkommando
der guardia civil zwei gesuchte es soll
sich um die deutschen chefs eines
drogenkartells handeln das auch
waffenhandel und geldwäsche betreibt die
deutsche polizei hatte über europol die
guardia civil verständigt dass die
beiden sehr gefährlich sein und
bewaffnet sein kann die guardia civil
entdeckte die beiden in einem hotel und
überraschte sie schließlich auf einer
terrasse am paseo marítimo in palma ein
spezialkommando für risiko einsätze
rückt an die elite polizisten fahren in
einem getarnten lieferwagen vor stürmen
des café und legen den gesuchten die
handschellen an anschließend werden die
verhafteten dem nationalen
strafgerichtshof in madrid überstellt
und nach deutschland ausgeliefert die
beiden kriminellen waren mit luxusautos
nach mallorca gereist in denen die
beamten 10.000 euro bargeld fanden ob
sie urlaub machen oder ihre geschäfte
auf die balearen ausweiten wollten ist
unklar
[Musik]